[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen sitzen micro
fällt meine lieben freunde so klein ist
unsere welt eigentlich gar nicht mehr
wir haben schon eine menge geschafft und
mit der zunehmenden dauer des projekts
neigt sich diese minecraft mit luca
serie auf dem ende zu in der letzten
episode haben wir jedes büro für unseren
flachbildfernseher kreiert und mir wurde
auch unter die letzte episode die
kommentare geschrieben luca die position
von der toilette da die ist ja echt
super gewählt denn hier beispielsweise
jemand hochkommen sieht erstmal den
schon ausblick bleibt dann hier lang und
sieht dann beim
dass da jemand auf toilette sitzt
und dann auch noch mit einer glastür
sofort also da hätte ich mir auf jeden
fall ein paar mehr gedanken machen
können die sache ist allerdings dass ihr
mann in die letzte folgen kommentar
sektion einige tipps beziehen wir sind
mehr oder weniger sogar vorschläge
reinschreiben solltet was ich noch in
diesem projekt machen soll was ich noch
bauen soll was noch offene punkte sind
die ich noch nicht abgearbeitet habe und
da wird mir so unfassbar viel
geschrieben das schaffe ich heute alles
gar nicht was allerdings mit am meisten
geschrieben wurde war erst mal kommen
wir das ja mal weg
weil ich das alles geschafft habe
übermorgen kommt denn jetzt mal in folge
und da werden wir dann noch ein paar
andere sachen machen die sache ist dass
ich mich heute erst mal eine sache
komplett raus hier ja da bleibt halt
hier ich will mich heute auf jeden fall
erstmal eine sache kümmern die mir sehr
häufig kommentare geschrieben wurde und
zwar war es der bunker
das sieht ziemlich beschissen hier aus
und ich habe mir eigentlich überlegt
dass sicherungen so eine art bunker
einbauen wenn oben irgendwie wieder ein
überfall ist dass es unser safe ruhm
wird und keine ahnung was die sache ist
allerdings als mir dann gedacht habe
mensch ist wird kein überfall mehr
passieren das einzige was ich noch groß
an action haben wir in diesem projekt
ist eigentlich in folge 100 dann wie ich
ins ende gehe da werden wir uns in über
nächsten folge auch darauf vorbereiten
und das ende suchen also bleibt auf
jeden fall dran lasten daumen runter mir
da und vor allem abonniert main kanal
damit ihr diese videos nicht verpassen
werdet allerdings habe ich mir gedacht
wir brauchen auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen was zu essen und ich habe
dieses gebratenen schweinefleisches will
allerdings trotzdem ist nicht zu viel
davon essen und die einzige farbe die
ich habe ist halt die farben die sich
unter hier wieder komplett action ist
halt diese farben da vorne und da passen
halt irgendwie nur 25 weizen drauf
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht und eine
unterirdische verein und dafür euch
jetzt auch direkt man eine time lab wie
ich mir nie ganz materialien zusammen
suche
[Musik]
so
hat jetzt nach halbe stunde gedauert
habe ich habe mir diese ganzen sachen
gerade zusammen gefragt und ich würde
auch sagen wir gehen direkt hier runter
und ich sag jetzt mal was sich hier vor
habe ich habe ja schon gesagt das ist
eine kleine farm werden soll allerdings
jetzt nicht irgendwie hier erde
reingezogen masters sondern ich will
dass ich alles ein bisschen auskleiden
und ein bisschen schön machen von daher
müssen wir erst mal provisorisch den
ganzen boden mit erde aus kleister damit
wir erst mal vernünftig bauen können das
wird natürlich nachher noch mal geändert
die sache ist allerdings dass ich jetzt
erstmal in ebenen untergrund brauche und
da macht dieses wasser hier keinen sinn
so dann haben wir jetzt hier auf jeden
fall schon mal das ganze wasser weg
am liebsten würde ich so einen kurzen
übergang haben und jetzt einmal sagen
und es ist fertig kriegen wir allerdings
nicht hin von daher müssen wir uns jetzt
erstmal darauf konzentrieren deswegen
ich werde hier auf jeden fall ein zwei
drei vier fünf blöcke entfernen die
werde ich ersetzen durch eichen
holzbretter damit wir im kleinen
übergang haben und hier die leiter dann
wieder neu ansetzen ich weiß auch gar
nicht wie ich die ganze zeit einfach so
gelassen haben konnte dass ihr und eine
leiter gefehlt hat wie das mein gehirn
überhaupt hingekriegt hat allerdings
haben wir jetzt quasi erst mal so und
nun erweitert mit dieser alten
holzbretter auf die linke seite um zwei
blöcke hier und auf der rechten seite um
einen sonne blog phase sage ich mal
alles was hier zu außen rum ist um die
leiter können wir hieraus cobblestone
machen und hier auf der seite habe ich
einmal ganz kurzen meine schaufel die
kaputten ist können wir auf jeden fall
hier auf der seite auch aus cobbelsdorf
machen dauert jetzt ein bisschen eine
schaufel
sonst sowieso noch gar nicht so schön
aus passt doch gar nicht so gut deswegen
nehmen wir unsere achse und entrinden
die in dem er ganz einfach mit dem recht
auf klicken wenn sie das ganze nämlich
schon mal so aus und genau das gleiche
machen wie er hat ja auch auf dieser
seite hier das ist jetzt ein bisschen zu
hoch da habe ich extra ein paar mehr
bruchsteine mitgenommen damit wir das so
ein bisschen abbilden können und hier
auch mit rechts drauf so wird das
nämlich nachher alles gestaltet sein
dass wird hier alles noch ein bisschen
schöner war sondern wird schon wieder
dunkel
wir haben hier unten einfach fast gar
kein licht brennen aber ist egal müssen
wir jetzt mit arbeiten hier auf die
seite kommen auf jeden fall auch eichen
holzbretter jetzt habe ich zum glück so
viel erde hier am start dass ich das
hier alles so ein bisschen zu teils sein
kann und ich weiß dass ihr hintern nicht
irgendwelche hohlräume sind also hier
nun auch die eichen holzbretter 1 4 x 4
x 5 sodass das ganze dann schlussendlich
so aussieht und wir nun hier wieder
einen fichtenstamm nach oben ziehen
können allerdings davor natürlich
erstmal ein bisschen erde hin hier kommt
der ybbs nähe so nicht hier kommt der
fichtenstamm in 1 23 höher kann ich
nicht deswegen 45 und hier hinter
natürlich wieder hochziehen damit wir
keine löcher irgendwie zu machen jetzt
natürlich wieder mit der achse rechtsweg
drauf und genau das gleiche machen wir
jetzt noch mal auf der seite und auf
dieser seite hier vorne
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde das ist jetzt
aktuell hier unser fortschritt ist
hingegen noch ziemlich nach dem krassen
rohbau aus ich weiß wird auf jeden fall
noch gebessert ich mache hier oben noch
mal eben kurz die löcher zu damit das
für meinen kopf trägt er das ja alles zu
ist wir müssen auf jeden fall hier vorne
erst mal dass ihr noch entrinnen fällt
mir gerade aus sagt das ist jetzt
natürlich bisschen blöd weil ich immer
die fackel in der hand habe und dann
müssen wir uns jetzt so ein bisschen
erstmal um die beleuchtung natürlich
kümmern dafür habe ich mir hier
polierten an die sieht mitgenommen und
laternen die wollte ich nämlich hier
einen davor setzen das wären wir hier 1
2345 fichtenstämme nach oben das heißt
dieser block er davor als wird ersetzt
durch einen polierten an die sieht und
da kommt immer eine laterne daran macht
zwar eigentlich mehr sind dass ich das
ganze jetzt zum schluss baut damit ihr
seht warum ich da extra an die sieht
nehme die sache ist allerdings dass wir
hier unten erst mal wirklich ein
bisschen beleuchtung brauchen so dass
nicht gleich irgendwelche monster swan
so haben wir auf jeden fall schon mal
alles ein bisschen beleuchtet und nun
greifen wir zu unseren 34 fichtenholz
treppen und jetzt erkennt ihr auch schon
warum ich hier extra die sachen
freigelassen habe bzw nur hier vorne das
eichenholz hingesetzt habe denn ich
hatte mir gedacht dass wir hier so
fichtenholz treppen dran platzieren
können jetzt müssen wir noch die
perfekte falsch ist natürlich gucken
dass wir die hier vorne irgendwie dran
gesetzt kriegen dann muss ich erstmal
hier alles so ein bisschen vorbereiten
allerdings können wir die dann jetzt
auch ganz easy überall ansetzen und ich
finde dass ich dann auch deutlich besser
aus als wenn wir das ganze einfach
freilassen würden beziehungsweise mit
anderen glocken füllen würden weil das
dann alles so ein bisschen abgerundet
aus jedoch wenn alles eckig es macht
keinen sinn aber ich glaub ihr wisst was
ich meine nun greifen wir zu unseren
polierten an die sie treppen und
platzieren diese hier zwischen den an
die sieht blöcken die wir hier an den
rand gesetzt haben und die unsere
beleuchtung darstellten so dass die
treppen quasi vom reichen holz in
fichtenholz übergehen und einen
polierten an die sieht
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir hier oben die erde
fläche bzw unsere decke noch perfekt auf
eine höhe denn darunter setzen wir nun
also stufen erst mal ganz prinzipielle
einsammeln und jetzt zeige ich euch mal
wie man das ganze macht und zwar einmal
die fichten holzstufen nehmen und die
polierten an die sieht stufen und wir
setzen jetzt hier immer so drei mal drei
felder an fichtenholz in also hier einst
natürlich hin zack dann hier vorne auch
noch mal einen dreier fällt das war
jetzt einer zu viel sagt zack zack da
muss ich mal ganz kurz wieder abbauen
und mit einer stufe ersetzen und genau
das gleiche jetzt auch noch mal hier auf
der anderen seite also hier einen dreier
fällt hier einen dreier feld und hier
vorne auch noch mal dazwischen setzen
wir nun unsere polierten an die sieht
stufen und bilden quasi hier seine reihe
die hier einmal durch geht so dass wir
hier oben dann quasi unsere decke haben
ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich hält
luca wenn man hier runter kommen was ist
dann mit dem eingang zur höhle gar kein
problem da machen wir ganz kurz das
ganze so dass wir das hier wieder
abbauen hier platzieren wir nun eine
fichtenholz treppe wie folgt und hier
vorne platzieren wir dann auch eine
fichtenholz türe dass wir entspannt rein
und rausgehen können habe ich auch extra
hier gemacht dann sieht das ganze
nämlich auch ganz cool aus so
abgeschnitten wir müssen dann nur noch
das hier natürlich durch eichen
holzbretter ersetzen ich habe jetzt
leider nur noch zwei von daher müsste
ich mir eins noch holen eben ganz kurz
von oben ich setze jetzt mal keine
reichen leute bretter hin sondern
einfach zwei stufen übereinander die
hatte ich gerade noch so perfekt in der
truhe oben liegen nun nehmen wir
allerdings unsere alten holztreppe mit
unserer sechs truhen und platzieren das
ganze hier wie folgt denn ich möchte
natürlich wohnen eine farm haben
deswegen macht es keinen sinn wenn man
immer nach oben laufen muss sondern die
ganzen sachen müssen natürlich hier
direkt zugänglich am start sein und nun
kommen wir auch endlich zum boden für
den boden habe ich mir nämlich überlegt
dass wir ein schachbrettmuster kreieren
ich sage mal eben ganz kurz hier nochmal
die erdbeeren damit alles ein bisschen
kinos und wir benötigen nun stein stein
ziegel und polierten an die sieht die
stein ziegel kommen nämlich erstmal hier
außen rum so ein bisschen alt
ja keine ahnung was ich glaube zu werden
hefts nicht cool ausgesehen wenn man die
stein ziegel er beziehungsweise den
steinen und den polierten an die sie bis
an den rand gezogen hätte das sei auch
gar nicht geklappt euch im
schachbrettmuster doch dann gehen wir
quasi hier einmal so durch mit dem
schneiden einmal quer und dann noch mal
hier auf der anderen seite also hier in
die ecke herein und auch nochmal hier
vorne sein und dann finden wir das ganze
so aus sodass immer zwischen den
steinblöcken ein blog frei ist stuck und
zack und in die freien blöcke
beziehungsweise freien felder hier platz
zehn minuten in polierten an dem sid ich
finde es richtig ist wenn man diese
löcher hier perfekt zu machen gerade
allerdings haben wir dann so ein kleines
schachbrettmuster hier unten und das
ganze sieht auch sehr sehr sehr sehr
geil aus bin ich wenn ich euch das
gleich mal zeige sieht mich so aus und
ist jetzt nicht so langweilig wie wir in
allenstein ziegel werden die tür habe
ich gerade aus dass ihnen abgebaut da
drunter her auch erde war die ich
entfernen musste das sieht dann hier so
aus und nun können wir uns auch auf den
wesentlichen teil konzentriert nämlich
zuerst einmal ganz kurz die fackeln ab
machen die waren ja eher provisorisch
und nun kommen wir zu dem feld was ich
mir überlegt habe da habe ich mich extra
schon erde mitgenommen einige kürbis
laternen einmal benötige ich dafür und
ich benötige auch noch die fichtenholz
falltüren das feld soll nämlich hier
vorne sein und es soll eine riesiges
feld sein also es wird wirklich bis wir
brauchen den drei weiten weg bis hier
vorne wird durchgezogen und dann an die
ecken und kanten kommen fichtenholz
falltüren so dass das ganze so ein
bisschen abgeschnitten ist genauso wie
die felder die wir bei unserer kleinen
villiger insel nebenan haben also hier
in den randschichten holz fall schön
platziert das machen wir jetzt auf jeder
seite und dann klappen wir die zeiten
natürlich auch ein so dass das ganze
feld so ein bisschen abgetrennt ist nun
nehmen wir wieder unsere erde schmerzen
die nicht hin sondern platzieren die
hier unrein dass wir hier natürlich
perfekt eine riesige fläche schaffen da
kommen gleich auch noch wasser rein war
jetzt natürlich unnötig dass ich hier
unten
die polierten handy sieht und den stein
und so weiter und so fort auch noch
eingepackt habe gott es regnet muss mir
noch einmal ganz fix wasser und ich hab
ein bisschen schiss dass von dieser
seite jetzt irgendwie ein monster kommt
haben wir allerdings noch mal glück
gehabt dies ist jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen material verschwinden aber ihr
wisst es mein auge ist nur zufrieden
wenn alles irgendwie perfekt ist wir
haben jetzt hier auf jeden fall einen
sechsten block breites feld platzieren
dementsprechend hier einmal wasser hier
in dem bereich das sind drei blöcke
abstand und hier vorne sind auch drei
blöcke abstand dh ich würde sagen sogar
er zwei blöcke abstand sie glaube ich
ein bisschen besser und wenn wir so
machen dann hier vorne das wasser und
dann können wir das hier wieder so
hinsetzen die nehmen wir nun den stein
und den anti sieht weg denn ich möchte
hier drunter kürbis laternen setzen
sodass wir auch ein bischen beleuchtung
haben da drauf kommt jetzt das wasser
genau so wie hier vorne bamm bamm bamm
und hier noch ein wassereimer rein um
mich die beiden jetzt noch einen topf
geholt habe weiß ich nicht allerdings
hatte ich mir eigentlich überlegen da
jetzt falten drauf zu machen sagt ist
allerdings dass wir dann natürlich das
licht nicht sehen durch die kürbisse
laternen deswegen können wir das ganze
auch umgehen indem wir uns einfach
einige seerosenblätter nehmen bzw wir
brauchen ja nicht einige sondern nur
vier stück sagt einmal zu machen und wir
setzen die einfach hier drauf sind dass
wir hier auch ein bisschen licht haben
nun nehmen wir uns unsere haake und sind
dann tatsächlich sogar auch schon fertig
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich noch ne harke
drin habe ich habe meine glück 1 hatte
ich habe keine ahnung warum ich die
nötige wird sie mir so viel glück
braucht auch sein ding aber ich kann
damit es noch klappt oder ob das licht
level zu gering ist oder ob das wasser
irgendwie falsch ist keine ahnung was
sieht allerdings ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
gut aus also es hat sich noch nicht
zurück zur erde verwandelt das hier
vorne wird sogar schon zu einem
dunkleren ding die glücks hacke ist
kaputt das ging jetzt relativ schnell
nehmen uns natürlich direkt eine neue
und machen den rest hier vorne auch noch
fertig wir testen das ganze dann gleich
auch noch mal und schon die ersten samen
an das einzige was ich unten eigentlich
sogar anbauen möchte sind weizen samen
davon habe ich auf jeden fall
eine menge am start habe ich nur zwei
perfekt das war jetzt
kurzes beispiel habe ich hier oben noch
mehr oder nicht ich habe habe ich auf
jeden fall noch eingeweihten können am
start waren hier noch alles voll das
müssen wir auf jeden fall noch rüber
bringen allerdings geht es mir jetzt
erst mal gerade ganz kurz uns an
pflanzen ob das alles funktioniert oder
ob da irgendetwas rausgeschmissen wird
von minecraft also auch irgendwelche
samen mit direkt wieder ein gegend
fliegen oder so
that's what i said sieht aber ziemlich
gut aus und ich glaube dass wächst auch
gleich alles dass wenn wir auf jeden
fall mal beobachten diese kiste hier ist
auf jeden fall für samen und hier kommen
alle anderen sachen rein es lohnt sich
ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr das jetzt hier
am ende des projekts wie trusts zu
sortieren und so weiter und so fort weil
wir auch demnächst dann in den end
bereich geben werden und uns dort so ein
bisschen umschauen werden
beziehungsweise hoffentlich den drachen
besiegen werden irgendwie erwartet jeder
gerade ganz schön viel von mir oder
perfekt das habe ich mir gedacht ich
nehme mal ganz kurz noch die weizen raus
und das hier alles und verfrachtet es
einmal ganz kurz darüber also eine ganz
kurze bleibst hier oben ist alles leer
hier ist alles leer ich habe euch jetzt
gerade auch mal keine teil mails
eingeblendet weil
anderthalb minuten hier hab ich gerade
noch mal alles abgebaut und neu
angepflanzt und ich sprinte jetzt auch
noch mal ganz schnell rüber auf unsere
insel denn da hinten haben wir auch noch
in der tour was ich wollte es ja
eigentlich provozieren dass wir unsere
wille job für uns die komplette
agrarwirtschaft übernehmen die haben
sich allerdings darum gekümmert und
schlussendlich bisher nichts passiert
und unsere gäste hier ist noch so gut
wie voll von daher nehme ich jetzt
einfach mal alles wieder raus mehr geht
nicht ich lasse auch noch die andere
hatte hier drin soll die brauche ich ja
nicht wir vorne wächst ein bisschen was
allerdings auch nicht allzu viel von
daher bringen wir die letzten sachen
jetzt noch mal habe ich irgendwas nicht
wenn ich die letzten sachen jetzt mal
ganz schnell runter unten in unseren
essens keller
vorratsraum ich würde einfach sagen wir
belassen es beim namen bunker weil das
war der name dem ich den ganzen zu
beginn gegeben habe zeigt hört zu hier
vorne habe ich mir gedacht mach ich
alles essen was ich eigentlich ähnlich
essen werde gleich wird auch ab und zu
zu gebraten und schweinefleisch gebracht
gegriffen ich glaube anders komme ich
auch nicht wirklich durch das ende durch
allerdings soll dass wir so ein bisschen
so die kisten mit den sachen die ich
ähnlich anrührend werde hier vorne
kommen dann so die ganzen pflanzlichen
dingen die man bauen kann wie
beispielsweise seetang hier vorne oder
zuckerrohr und
kürbiskerne und rote beete samen und
weizenkörner und kartoffeln pakistan
wiederum hier rein und die kürbisse kann
ich zwar nicht essen und packe ich da
noch gar nicht hier rein aber rote beete
kommt dir eine melone kommt hier ein
pilz kommt noch nach oben kohl versprach
ich hier mit rein und den getrockneten
vitamin kann man ja auch essen also
packe ich auch noch jemand rein und den
fisch esse ich nicht den parcours die
eier kann ich mal ganz kurz
reinschmeißen da wird nichts rauskommen
zackig habe nämlich nie glück bei sowas
und die letztlichen die restlichen
sachen die ich gerade wie ich gerade
gesagt habe die hier oben hin kommen die
packt jetzt einfach mal hier rein die
gold spitzhacke kommen natürlich je
vornherein und diana sieht satten passen
hier glaube ich nicht mehr rein dann
nehme ich jetzt einfach mal die gäste
ihr provisorisch also meine lieben
freunde ist klar alle mal eben kurz die
sachen die ich am start noch hatte man
inventar und zwar das der stärke bogen
und die fackeln und natürlich mein
schild ohne dass ich niemals überleben
werde in den nächsten folgen das traue
ich mir nämlich ganz kurz aus und dann
schauen wir uns mal an was sie hier
unten geschafft haben ich glaube die
folge war jetzt tatsächlich gar nicht
mal so extrem lang ich glaube es war der
normale durchschnittliche volk ich
dachte sie wird länger weil das ein
großes projekt hier unten war allerdings
habe ich ja viel mit taxis gearbeitet
und ich finde es ist sehr geil geworden
weil wir so ein bisschen tiefer drin
haben weil das hier unten nicht direkt
runter geht das feld des abgetrennt wir
haben hier einen perfekt symmetrischen
dreier weg der hier lang geht dann kommt
man quasi runter wenn man in die höhle
will kann man hier einfach runter gehen
in die höhle allerdings ist der vorraum
hier unser kleines lager und unsere
ganzen sachen sind hier drin die wir
essen wir sie nicht essen können ich bin
sehr zufrieden ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wenn es das getan hat dann das
gern einen daumen hoch unter dem video
da meine lieben freunde abonniert main
kanal und klickt selbstverstänlich auf
die glocke wenn die nächste episode
übermorgen nicht verpassen wollen
übermorgen wird eine episode werde ich
komplett auf kommentare einig werden
freund fürs schwein suchen ich werde mal
wieder zum skelett bonner gehen ich
werde mir sachen verzaubern ich werde
bei der villa die den glasboden für die
korallenriffe chemischen ganz viele
sachen aufgeschrieben
[Musik]